agenda is said hello everyone I'm Brent
Goff in Berlin what does a u.s.
president do when politics and the
public seem to be turning against him
well he takes a lesson from history and
he goes to Berlin today on the show
Europe and the world reading Obama it's
time to talk at the g8 summit in
Northern Ireland the leader of the free
world had a lot of explaining to do
surveillance scandals Guantanamo drones
suddenly Obama's image as mr. can do
could do with some tweaking despite all
their delts Europeans are genuinely
excited about Obama's visit but there's
also a real fear that the transatlantic
love affair has become very platonic
this was Obama the candidate back in
2008 promising in Berlin that
Washington's first foreign love will
always be European this month the long
reach of history from JFK to the Berlin
Airlift will demand a renewal of those
valves Europe remains the least of
Obama's worries the rest of the world is
demanding his attention and demanding
u.s. foreign policy include action not
just words consider the trouble spots
the Secretary of State John Kerry is
tending to non-stop Israel and the
Palestinians still no peace Iran and the
u.s. still not talking and is Obama's
red line in Syria real well I've invited
three people the dates you talk argue
and kind of pry apart and scratch at the
image of Obama's presidency as it stands
today and what his visit here in Berlin
will mean for the world and my first
guess she is living the transatlantic
life she knows the workings of
Washington and she is now a Berliner I'm
happy to welcome to the show sudha David
Webb she's with the German Marshall Fund
suit is good to have you on the show
today my second guest is jakub schrott
he is president of the young
transatlantic initiative that is a
non-profit group
cated to strengthening ties between
Germany and the u.s. so he's well
positioned to sit beside you suited and
my third guest is Yosef yawning a fellow
at the German society for Foreign
Relations many would say that is the
leading foreign policy think tank here
in Germany it was good to have you on
the show let's start with all of you
with this premise Obama is coming to
Berlin as a president who has failed us
can we say that or can we say that the
world back in 2008 set him up to fail
what do you say soon I think that Oh bah
failed is a too strong of a word I think
there is disappointment on this side of
the Atlantic when it comes to Obama's
policies just subjects such as
Guantanamo climate change those were
things that he had mentioned that he'd
wanted to tackle during his first term
and it just didn't happen because of
gridlock in the United States and most
Europeans I think are disappointed but
failure is too strong of a word fa is
too strong a word but i think if we
looked at any group that is most
disappointed yakov that would be
europe's young people Germany's young
people I mean they almost the blade
treated Obama like a rock star in 2008
well I would make a difference between
the opinion of young people and people
in Europe especially with regard to the
President and to the United States as a
whole so the president still enjoying
overwhelming approving rates here in
Germany we have eighty eighty-five
percent of young people who approve the
current job of the president but if it
comes to topics like want animal-like
drone strikes Germans are very very
skeptical and actually we have not
recovered yet from the post Eirik war
time and the German attitude is still
very skeptical with regard to the United
States because what do you say is Obama
almost a victim of all this goodwill
that was given to him back in two
thousand eight yeah sure I remember the
time when after his election when he was
president elect but not in office and
and everybody was discussing is it at
all possible
that he could deliver on the
expectations and many people already
then said no it's impossible now as soon
as he's president he will face all the
constraints all the difficulties of this
job and then it is simply not possible
to carry on this sword of charismatic
can do message into an office that
already has to deal with Congress it has
to deal with the outside world all that
I mean true it's it's hard to go from
being a cheerleader to being a player on
the team we also have to remember too
that time has changed the world the
world in 2013 looks very different from
the world in 2008 when Barack Obama was
catapulted to the office of the
president of the United States the most
powerful man in the world possessed the
most powerful ammunition every elected
leader dreams up the goodwill of most
people the world in 2008 could not get
enough of Barack Obama we saw that of
course here in Berlin the hopes
surrounding him were so high that a
reality check tending towards the
negative was pre-programmed the latest
gallup poll i've got the numbers here
shows that forty seven percent of
americans approve of obama's job forty
five percent do not at home and abroad
barack obama is now criticized all modes
as much as he is celebrated on monday US
President Barack Obama spoke to Northern
Ireland youth about progress through
peace fill me with hope an optimistic
charismatic president first elected in
2008 with promises of change is now
coming under fire on a number of issues
Obama has not followed through on his
promise to shut the doors of the prison
in Guantanamo Bay the detention facility
has badly damaged America's reputation
as a defender of Human Rights
the Nobel Peace Prize winner has also
drawn criticism for his drone war
activists say over 3,000 innocent
civilians have been killed in drone
strikes against suspected terrorists
when you see every and Edward Snowden's
leaked revelations about the NSA
electronic surveillance program has
alienated even the most ardent former
Obama supporters on social media Barack
Obama has gone from yes we can to yes we
scan yeah I mean you know we chuckle
about that I'm bday it's quite an
indictment you know he's had one term
he's in a second now and you know
suddenly everyone's talking about him
being part of the establishment he's
actually having to say in public that
he's not like Dick Cheney sudah what in
the world has happened yeah I think you
know a people on the Left not it's not
just the half of America that didn't
want obama in office that's disappointed
with the way America is going I think
many people on the Left we're also
hoping that Obama could change things
but you know we do just to go quickly
back to your question about failure I
mean there are many things we forget he
did enact a new health care policy for
the United States he did go after Obama
Osama bin Laden and get get him but yes
I think people are disappointed with
this latest scandal with the leaks that
have been happening and the intrusion on
privacy in the United States and abroad
and I think it is worrisome for people
on both sides of the political spectrum
but what is it though about his his
presidency right now I mean why is the
Teflon why has that been removed you
know the first four years a lot of
people said that he could do no wrong
that's not the case now how is that
possible because the time he can blame
this process at george w bush's over now
the people are thinking about what have
you done in the last four years and now
it's up to him to show his record and
despite the health care reform and osama
bin laden there is actually not lot not
much she can present to the American
public from immigration reform to
background checks everything failed
foreign policies catastrophe so far and
Obama presidency there is no grand
straight
g40 Arab uprising not is it I mean is
that true wasn't one of the first things
that Obama did was you know he went to
Cairo and he gave this speech you know
he wanted reconciliation right with son
Arab world at the same time he gave to
speech in Cairo he cut all the money for
not African state for civil society and
then and when when the people really
rised against dictators in the gay
against Authority rule the United States
was actually not supporting the
protesters in the way he said in a Cairo
speech the stairs money and there is
still yeah there's still I mean you know
Joseph can we say that it has Obama has
he dropped the ball here or has Congress
I mean he is he's the president he's not
the king on that Congress actually was
to take the blame on this Obama is to
take the blame for raising expectations
extremely high among especially the
young urban Arab population about a new
approach to this about somebody who
would who would find a way between the
surge of Islamic identity which also the
young people in the cities feel in their
claim to build a sort of a modern
effective efficient opportunity granting
sort of political and economic
environment he was the man to do it he
disappointed them because it didn't
deliver well he has always stayed on
message you know we yes we can or we are
all in this together you know he is a
president he believes in a social
contract he's always been on message can
we hold him responsible for how the
world receives the message I mean that's
that point right he's told us what he
what he wants his vision is clear isn't
it right but i also think Brent back to
your question about the the White House
press corps to i think has also lost a
little bit of the love affair with
president obama thank you during the
first administration it was very
hesitant wanted to give him a chance but
journalists now feel that the obama
white house has also been very secretive
not being wilt not very communicative
taking the press for granted and i think
they're coming out a little harder and
actually questioning what this
administration is achieved I mean there
is a lot of secrecy in this White House
that people are shocked about
and should we be so shocked well I think
it's we're gradually waking up to a new
world and i think obama is also waking
up to this you know it's he's the first
president who really has engaged in
drone strikes which is an entirely new
type of you know war right it's people
sitting somewhere in in the bunkers in
the US operating this he is the first
president who has the technological
ability to actually screen a
communication of not only most Americans
but most of the world in you know he's
not used to it he didn't grow up with
this he doesn't have an idea how this
all relates to his is rather civil
liberty approach that he takes after all
you know this is his training he's a
constitutional lawyer so he should be
deeply concerned but he has no response
yet how are we dealing with his
technological possibility does believe
though in the system of checks and
balances in oversight I mean that's why
he has said public he said I mean he
brought he's an attorney you know he
understands American law and he has come
out and said he believes that the
oversight system will work he doesn't
think he thinks it's a benevolent system
that we're talking about we're talking
about surveillance but is anyone
believing that I think he does but it's
about turning words into deeds and I
think this is always also but yours f
yawning said so on the one hand you can
announce and in Cairo or in Prague will
be 0 but the question is what you
actually do afterwards so giving speech
and presenting the message is the one
thing but turning words into deeds us a
different thing and so the president of
course now has a strategy to go out to
the public and to announce his policy
because they want to pressure Congress I
think it's the right thing to do but
still it's it's a little a little bit
strange at the liberal Constitution
professor from Harvard is actually
engaging in drone strikes which still
have some question with regard to
international law in the way Josh the
bush that's never done and and ii III do
you know i think your points about
taking years if I mean he is going into
territory that know where the president
has had to deal with and maybe they're
making it up as they go along but and
there are people and I'm going to get
back to this point about you saying he
says one thing but doesn't follow
through there are a lot of people in
Washington now
talking about Obama being the president
of style and not a president of
substance yeah when I read that and I
think of what we were saying in 2008 I
mean it's like somebody you know we must
have been drunk in 2008 I mean how is
that possible suitor that they think
that the man has no substance I don't
think that's entirely true i think it's
every politician likes to play with
imagery and rhetoric but of course the
man has substance otherwise he wouldn't
be where he is today there is no way he
could have gone through that grueling
process of going through a primary with
hillary clinton becoming the democratic
nominee and then winning in 2008 the man
has substance but he also has many
domestic challenges we mentioned checks
and balances he has to work with
Congress there are things he'd like to
do but America is really split down the
middle it's a fifty fifty percent or
fifty fifty and going back to this
question of drones it's going to you
know 22 we can look back maybe in 10
years and say if this is was a good
policy or not but a slight majority of
Americans actually don't have a problem
with the drone policy and we're coming
to combating terror own the drone
dialogue actually is taking place here
in Europe the Europeans get much more
upset about drones about surveillance
than the Americans you fly to the states
and people you know they look at you
they say what's the big deal it happens
elsewhere happens elsewhere well they
know their their phones and their emails
are being checked too but it doesn't but
they say it doesn't bother them there's
a certain irony in this with Obama I
think that man has a lot of substance
actually has a lot of conviction
probably more substance and more
conviction than its predecessor but he's
actually week on the point where people
thought he is so strong you know facing
all the difficulties that sudah was
mentioning now a communicator a
charismatic person appealing to a broad
public like Obama he should be working
hard to find a way how to communicate
his message his message of what is
needed in in welfare one with her issues
on domestic policy on economic recovery
on jobs on education
to an electorate that is skeptical you
know after all this is what brought him
into office his enormous communication
skills but on that on formulating a
message of substance he's rather weak he
would probably prefer a position to do
to kind of live out all of his substance
in the White House with Congress
applauding to it but facing this this
deadlock in Congress and also in the
country he seems unsure on how to
overcome this well he's yeah he's trying
to convince people that he's right yeah
and but he insists on his position
rather than trying to win people are
saying he needs I mean if I mean it's
amazing but I think what you're saying
is Obama needs a little bit of Ronald
Reagan maybe yeah maybe in all this
simplicity Reagan was a very effective
communicator right it was more effective
as president than he was as candidate
but you know there's an old adage in
politics Mario Cuomo said you campaign
in poetry but you you you know you
govern in prose and I think that's
something that Obama struggles with like
I agree with you he's a much better
campaigner than he is when it comes to
actually governing and off and if you go
outside to the public and and and you
struggle for public opinion for example
if you take the example of background
checks there's an overwhelming majority
in America eighty percent for better
background checks when it comes to two
guns but still the United States Senate
is of course not voting in favor items
so public opinions extremely important i
totally agree he has to get out washing
DC has to get two to two hundred America
he has to struggle for opinions but at
the end of the day the United States
Senate and the House of Representatives
are going to make a decision so maybe
that's why he's coming to Berlin let me
throw that out there you know other
presidents have done that you know JFK
did it Reagan did Bill Clinton did it is
Obama coming to Berlin to set the record
straight and to let us know what kind of
world he is leading us into I think
there's a there's a big difference
between this visit and previous visits
by previous presidents when President
Kennedy came his message in Berlin was
also a
sent at home now with Obama come in here
in the current American political
situation it is not very relevant now
here in this situation Obama comes to
Europe to deliver a message to Europe
that is basically a message to kind of
pick up a little bit the pieces get some
momentum again and and win some more
confidence in Europe and have a
reflection of that represented somehow
in the American media I want to pick up
on that too oz of the visit of Obama to
Berlin this week is part of a long
narrative between the US and Europe that
has its focal point as we said right
here in Berlin just think of the Berlin
Airlift think of the Berlin Wall you
cannot tell a transatlantic story
without including Berlin and it US
presidents as we said they've always
recognized that Ronald Reagan came here
in 1987 using this city to transmit the
message that the world had had enough of
the Iron Curtain and it was 50 years ago
this month when JFK came to Berlin
offering a personal pledge to everyone
in Berlin that the US would not allow
them to become casualties of the cold
war ich bin ein valina
john f kennedy's immortal words
symbolized the special post-world war
two relationship between Germany and the
u.s. Berlin's geopolitical importance
became even clearer during the Cold War
when the Soviets launched the Berlin
Blockade the US and its allies made the
unprecedented move of air lifting
supplies into the city when in 2008 the
den presidential candidate barack obama
took his campaign to Berlin this was
seen as a clear nod to the enduring
transatlantic partnership but now with
the u.s. turning its focus towards Asia
many in Europe wonder if the u.s. still
values is traditional partners and that
is the fear going through Europe isn't
it that the United States with Obama is
turning its back and looking towards
Asia Europe is done we've taken care of
Europe and isn't that the fear here
knows what do you say in a way it is but
I don't know if it if here is so much
the word I think it is it is a bit of a
disappointment of not being in the
limelight of u.s. foreign policy any
longer because it has been very
convenient has been very reassuring very
comfortable for the Europeans to know
that their primary concerns at the same
time or concerns of any American
president and now Europeans must face a
situation where the Americans simply
follow the priority of their interests
and that means that indeed Europe is not
in danger Europe is not threatened
currently by anyone in Europe should and
has to be able to take care of its own
interests and that is something that the
Europeans are a little bit uneasy with
because they haven't found a way to do
this yeah and that means we're speaking
different languages now I mean when
we're talking about foreign policy and
it hasn't been that way for a long time
but one of the greatest problems is that
we almost exclusively focus on history
and transcending relations so usually we
talk about the building
lived upon Jeff Campbell and Ragnar
Moline Bush Senior and his effort to for
a German reunification but we do not
discuss how should the transatlantic
relations should look like in three or
four decades we are we are captured in
history and so we have a project now
which is the transatlantic free trade
agreement but there is no common ground
on major foreign policy issues from
climate change okay migration is it this
is reprising their this train do common
ground this trade deal that was huge i
mean it's going it's going to be the
biggest free trade zone in the world
absolutely and there are a lot of people
who read into it as the Americans and
the Europeans are working together to
create a power that can what deal with
China absolutely so Europe remains
relevant I think the pivot to Asia is a
little bit exaggerated here in Europe I
think the Europeans are much more feared
about much more afraid about this pivot
to Asia than the United States actually
but if we for example look at the poles
on the ground in the United States more
than two-thirds of young Americans say
that Southeast Asia is going to be the
most relevant partner for DNS us in
future while the older generation say of
course it's Europe so we see a major
shift here and Congress appears to think
that too I was talking last week with
people I'm from New York and Washington
who do all types of exchange programs
with with students and with young
professionals Congress is planning to
cut a lot of these subsidies they don't
see a need anymore for that and it's
kind of crazy right because if you
didn't have those programs people like
suta for example people like me we
wouldn't even exist so the bridge
building that has been going on some
people say is being taken for granted I
mean sudha you know how it is in
Washington they think Europe is one of
those expenses you know we can do away
with that's right i mean i think also we
should probably say you know the new
word is not pivot it's rebalancing think
the United States wants to reassure its
partners in Europe that they are still
indispensable and are you know the
premier partners when it comes to
setting a trade agenda when it comes to
common values and Asia is also important
I mean President Obama mentioned his
State of the Union address not just the
T tip the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership he also mentioned
TPP right there really
straddling both the Pacific and the
Atlantic and rightly so because in this
age where prosperity is not what it used
to be maybe in the 90s the United States
needs to look for growth everywhere not
just in Europe but yaakov has a good
point though we struggle today to find
common ground on a lot of things in an
environmental policy this is an example
the death penalty is an example gun
control some people would say as an
example isn't there an argument to be
made that in the 21st century America is
much further away than it was in the
20th century well these issues have been
around you know the gun issue the death
penalty issue you know the differences
in our preferences have been around for
quite some time and still trade across
the Atlantic is what three billion a day
three billion dollars a day which is a
mature relationship and I think insofar
as as this is beneficial to both sides
and it is both sides will look at each
other will focus on each other but on
the other hand I mean you have to take
the view from from the White House or
from the Pentagon or from the the
economic actors the business sectors in
the United States the there's the mature
market on the one end pretty secure
pretty stable not delivering all the
time but okay and there's enormous
growth potential in East Asia there is
the hub of global controversy now is
over East Asia the region is the the
world's center of arms imports nobody
buys more arms also from Europeans and
Americans then actors in East Asia but
any incoming president when when he's or
she's briefed will learn that the
principal challenger of the United
States on the global stage is not Europe
is not Russia is China and you know the
Americans look at things many times the
way first things first yep its
solidarity is no longer a given i mean
let's look at what's going on in Syria
right now you know the you was you know
many would say that obama is still not
about what he wants to do he's you know
he and the UK appear to be on the same
page but then you've got France and
Germany on another what how do you find
common ground and we had a similar
situation in Libya where the Germans
they abstained you did not have that
unconditional support you know I think
President Obama is also coming to Berlin
because he really recognizes Germany as
a great power I mean and that Germany
shouldn't feel shy about this sort of
title and I think sudha and when I have
to call you on that okay okay Obama has
been in office now four and a half years
and he has made eight trips to Europe
since he became president this is the
first time he's come to Germany Germany
is the most important economy in Europe
I mean he's really good I mean his
learning curve here seems to be exactly
but now I really pleased you were
falling apart and saying we need Europe
and the country that's gonna be able to
pull Europe together as Germany you know
and and not just economic prowess but I
think he also wants to see Jeremy
starting to share the burden when it
comes to creating a stable world I'm not
sure about this so when President Obama
was still senator and he was the
chairman for Subcommittee on Europe he
was not visit in Germany once during its
time yet not had a single hearing about
about Europe as the president of the
Subcommittee on Europe and so right now
so that's that's again he's going to
have the speech in front of the
hamburger gate of course but at the end
of the day what is about the precise
policy what is the common ground on
climate change on migration on Syria
Iran Libya if it comes to real hard
policy we still struggle to find common
ground and so once more turning words
into deeds which is not only to blame
President Obama we see the German
position on Libya for example which I
totally disagreed with the German
reluctance to to have a fair share in
many episodes though the point is you do
have these divisions now that come up
again and again and you just you can't
Bank on support like you you could 20
years you can also mention Germany twice
in State of the Union speeches and I
think it's hard to find common ground
when the partners within Europe are
having a hard time finding common ground
actually I think if you'd asked the
White House staff they would probably
say Obama is quite frustrated about
Berlin because he has made so many
advances to Chancellor America this
freedom novel things stayed dinner thing
the boys not just because such she's
such a nice person it was because Obama
was trying to communicate to Berlin we
think you're important we think you're
privileged right back to what you said
earlier is that he wants us to get the
message but he can't deliver it I mean
is that what's happening what he
intended to to win a partner that would
say yes we're willing to go out of our
usual ways we're willing to go along
with you on things in the world that are
troubling us together Merkel did not
respond along these lines she you know
she took up the kind offers but she
didn't deliver and Obama frankly had no
idea how he could win her very much
unlike Cameron or Sarkozy in his time he
can't do like George Bush didn't try to
give her a shoulder massage right so I
mean what's he gonna do you know
together so the middle of freedom right
his problem is how to deal with a
country that that doesn't want to move
now that doesn't want to take risks that
doesn't want to go out of its usual way
how to deal with the Germans is what
you're talking about yeah I mean that's
it you know that's that's a completely
different show you know but I mean it is
a good point um could we make the
argument that maybe Angela Merkel hasn't
been it hasn't heard the message as
clearly as Obama would like because she
is so busy dealing with Europe's
problems and for the first time in a
long time the plate is full and there
isn't a lot of extra capacity for
dealing with another superpower I think
she's chosen to overhear some of the
undertones and his message now also
remember when she was struggling with
your
crisis in 2009 2000-2010 there was a lot
of ready advice from Washington on what
they should do yes and most of that
advice was spent more consume or go down
that way and she was absolutely
convinced that she would not hold us she
would not hold such a policy in the
light of the skeptic German public in
light of the situation around Europe so
she thought the advice from washing was
actually rather counterproductive in
terms of her own choice so her best bet
to react to Obama's foreign policy moves
was to simply not to listen to close
that's true i mean you know we reported
on this many times timothy geithner
would come over and he would tell
wolfgang schauble or the finance
minister you guys need to do this you
need to spend money you know you need to
lower your taxes and in the way he would
say it too was very you know it wasn't
the nicest way but they heard that over
and over again but they never changed
their policy let's get back to Trenton
Ling relations for a second i think
transit line relation what is the heart
of it it is not only a nice phrase but
it is what the people on both sides of
the Atlantic Ocean think of each another
so transatlantic relations are too
important to only focus on a rose garden
event for Chancellor Merkel or whether
diplomats get along with another at the
munich security conference is about what
stereotypes we have in mind if we think
of a battery what german think about
Americans and Americans are drivers and
here we have a huge decline in public
opinion especially in Germany about them
about the United States and this is what
bothers me the most with the future of
this relation well couldn't you say
though that the fact that Germany you
know is allowing Obama to speak in front
of the Brandenburg Gate that in itself
is a sign of tremendous affection for
Obama I mean you know she you know
miracle could have block that the fact
that they're allowing him to come back
and to stand in front of the Brandenburg
Gate that isn't that a sign of isn't
that a renewal of the vows but you know
of alignment and and friendship and
trust and common values I don't see how
she could have blocked that exactly I
think she actually invited him if i'm
not mistaken so yeah so you tip you're
not telling to make up for last time
exactly right he had to earn it that is
what she's saying all right um yeah
let's move on and talk a little bit more
about foreign policy President Obama is
spending part of the week here in
Germany and will then head to Tanzania
South Africa and Senegal America's reach
some would say is the only remaining
superpower continues to be huge but most
people today talk about the rising
powers in Asia and the BRIC economies
and in the same breath they usually
speak of the decline of American
influence around the globe now this
place is the president will talk about
this in a second in a very difficult and
delicate position on the one hand he is
charged with preparing America for a
21st century in which power is
multipolar at the same time people
continue to knock at his door demanding
he intervene in conflicts far away they
say the US remains the only country that
has both the might and the right just
months into his second-term Obama is
facing a number of foreign policy
challenges one of his first moves was to
send Secretary of State John Kerry on a
whirlwind tour of many of the world's
troubled spots in Israel Kerry embarked
on intense days of shuttle diplomacy but
so far has little to show for it
us-iranian relations are as bad as ever
with a new Iranian president and office
the u.s. might try to engage
diplomatically with Tehran Syria is
another hot spot one that Obama will be
trying to avoid getting too deeply
involved in during the Arab Spring the
US was conspicuous in its absence in
Libya Obama did get some praise at home
for maneuvering his European partners
into the driver's seat so isn't this
really what is driving a wedge between
Europe and the United States it's
American foreign policy the Americans as
many would say they still have the power
to do what they want militarily and they
do that and that's what the drone issue
is about and it's not a big issue in the
states is it Sudha no it's not but i
think you know if you look deeper maybe
that's the divided among them in the
public but when it comes to decision
makers i think the issue is europe
europe is immersed in itself it's
immersed in trying to reinvigorate the
European project so it's having a hard
time working with partners in or working
with their counterparts in Washington to
flesh out a u.s. foreign policy or
transatlantic foreign policy because
Europe is also trying to solve problems
at home right now with the euro crisis I
mean so is it you know is it you know
building some castle in the sky to think
that there could be some common American
European foreign policy dealing with
what's happening in Asia or you know
dealing with the rise of even of South
America you know is it is that plausible
I don't really see this I don't think
that any US administration would be
particularly keen to see Europe
conducting policy in South America or
Blige in the United States to consult
with Europe on South America on Asia the
story would be somewhat different
because they're you and we have this
free trade agreement which is just as
much about about military power as it is
economic power if you read between the
lines
on on Asia you have an an explicit
American interest to be able to set the
terms of trade when it comes to to
business as China enters the world
economy has a powerful actor the US
wants to use the momentum that there is
and that is mostly in the in the u.s.
European economic relationship and its
impact on the global economy to to
somehow adapt the rules so that china is
not entering into a major rewriting
business but rather is is is nudged to
accept these I mean China's one thing
what about Israel and the Palestinians
you know you hear all the time here in
Europe the Americans are the reason why
we don't have a peace agreement if Obama
wanted to he could exert pressure and
Israel and the Palestinians would sit
down and talk well first it's true that
America likes to solve those problems on
their own so they don't want to have
Brussels or anyone else to make the
decision for themselves on the other
hand for example if we see the Chicago
summit of NATO we have a clear road map
of smart defence of burden sharing but
we make no progress here which is
largely because of the Europeans because
of our cuts on our defense budgets here
but with regard to Israel and Palestine
so the question is what is the heart
what is the bottom of the problem in the
Middle East and so Obama considered
Israel Palestine as s domain as the main
problem to solve the surrounding
problems as well but it's such a
frustrating topic and John Kerry's not
going to solve it President Obama start
going to solve them there is no momentum
we hear it though if you go anywhere in
the air board if you talk to people who
want reform they tell you that
successful reform is not going to come
pieces not going to come until the
israeli-palestinian problem is solved if
everyone's telling is that why is it
Obama using the power he has to make
peace it's not over yet he still has
time left in a second term and if you
look in the past American presidents
like Clinton spent time in the middle
east toward the end because they don't
want to exhaust power resources on such
an intractable problem intractable
problem like the Middle East when there
are a lot of things that he has to take
care of at home first but Obama like we
talked about building he's about style
about image
he's gonna want to worry about his
legacy yeah he's like this and i think
the middle east maybe because he started
out going to cairo at the beginning so
maybe by the end of the beginning so by
the will come full circle perhaps at the
end well he should have engaged a bit
more intensively by now then if that was
him because he should remember how Bill
Clinton ended with the best of
intentions with a good record think of
the North Island breakthrough that he
established he started in his second
administration to launch a major
breakthrough and he came very close to
it towards the end of the second term
but he didn't have the time to twist the
arms of the Palestinians for long enough
in order to have them except that's
right there and that's what I've been
trying to get you all to you know to say
what is the significance of the speech
in front of the Brandenburg Gate this
week is this going are we going to see
Obama beginning to build his legacy this
this week not in Europe that's not the
appropriate place i think i think the
speech will be about historical ties
which about this it will be a
reassurance we build rebalancing that
United States not going to forget
Germany and Europe as a whole but it's
not going to be legacy building legacy
building station but can it be a forum
for him to say look at what we have in
common this should be an example for
example for what's happening in Turkey
the Turks can look to Europe into the
u.s. as you know role models that peace
can work I mean this is an excellent
opportunity she's gonna say Germany is
an example exactly peaceful transition
yeah Germany should play a role in world
affairs and showing people how they
brought you know how they overcome evil
came division and came together in a
bloodless revolution mm-hmm I mean that
that's possible isn't it he's going to
sing the praises of the success of peace
which is right here in Berlin I think he
will try to be entirely positive in his
communication so he will not speak about
the u.s. turning away or you Europe not
delivery he will
rather speak about the high expectations
you know the the enormous record of
Europe and and the possibilities that
there are if only we look at the world
together and you know identify the
challenges and act upon them this is the
sort of message that is to be expected
but we haven't touched on a lot in what
you know I want to before we run out of
time is is the war on terror and our
America and Europe on the same page with
that if you know if we say we're not on
the same page when it comes to drones
where are we on the same page sudha it's
a good question and I think also just
we're talking about history here just
because of the you know historical
connotations here in Berlin of where
there was a Stassi and half of the city
or maybe all over the city survey that
you know doing surveillance on people
private citizens I think that's going to
be this is going to be a stumbling block
but it can be overcome you know this
this is definitely overshadowing the
visit but it Tara terrorism hasn't
happened here we're running out of
question half time I got two questions I
need yes or no answers from all of you
the speech in Berlin this week will it
be historic policymaking speech from
Obama yes or no sudha no no okay
President Obama himself will he go down
in history as being one of the most
important US presidents yes no yes yes
okay the yeses habit all right the
positive voices went out on agenda
almost every week we do that that is
going to wrap up my agenda this week
don't forget you can watch the show
again on our website and on YouTube and
don't be shy tell us what you think
about the show our inbox is always open
you see the address there on the screen
I'm Brent Goff in Berlin as I am every
week join me next time when I set the
agenda
you
you